[Music]
thank you
in his essay on fairy stories J.R.R
Tolkien is going to make a very
interesting set of remarks in the course
of discussing the origins of fairies
stories and he's going to talk about
three faces of this type of narrative so
what are these well here's how the
passage goes he's talking about the
mythology and you know the idea of
divinity and the Supernatural and he
says
these things have in fact become
entangled or maybe they were sundered
long ago and have since groped slowly
through a Labyrinth of error through
confusion back towards refusion coming
back together and then he says even
fairy stories as a whole have three
faces well what are these so there you
could say the three M's the mystical the
magical and the mirror so what are each
of these he tells us that there's the
mystical
towards the supernatural the magical
towards nature and the mirror there's a
little bit of a lack of parallelism here
the mirror of scorn and pity towards man
or towards Humanity so three different
faces three different different
functions you could say of the fairy
tale narrative three different ways in
which it can be connected with other
matters so the mystical connections to
mythology as he's going to have pointed
out and point out some more in this in
the mirror of scorn and pity towards
Humanity it can include satire which
he's already discussed a little bit
earlier in the work as one of the
purposes of fairy tales certain fairy
tales at least and he pointed out that
the one thing you can't satirize is the
magic or as he's going to call it a
little bit later the enchantment right
so you know each of these is you could
say a legitimate
mode or as he's going to call it a face
turned towards something that we find in
the fairy story he tells us though that
the magical is
the one that is the essential face of
fairy right not a fairies as such but of
the realm of fairy that in his view uh
is is the best way to understand what a
fairy tale is so these other two faces
could be involved and in fact they often
are as he tells us the degree in which
the others appear if at all
is variable and may be decided by the
individual Storyteller so
you can have fairy tales that are
entirely driven by this magical aspect
or Dimension and are not interested in
the mystical and the supernatural or are
not interested in making you could call
them biting harsh judgments and
extending pity towards Humanity
on the other hand you can have these as
he points out he tells us that the
magical the fairy story may be used as a
mute water de loam right a mirror of The
Human Condition and it may but not so
easily be made a vehicle of mystery and
he says this is at at least what George
McDonald attempted achieving a stories
of power and Beauty when he succeeded as
in the golden key which he called the
fairy tale and even when he partly
failed as in Lilith which he called a
romance now
this is an interesting passage and I
think that it's pregnant with a bit more
when we read other parts of this essay
in relation to it so if we backtrack a
little bit we find him saying
that an essential power of fairy is the
power of making immediately effective by
the will
the visions of fantasy now he points
something out quite important here and
fantasy is a term he's going to use
quite a lot in the essay not all are
beautiful or even wholesome
not at any rate the fantasies of Fallen
man and he has Stained the elves who
have this power inverity or fable with
his own stain
this aspect of Mythology sub creation
rather than either representation or
symbolic interpretation of the Beauties
and tears of the world is I think too
little considered is that because it's
seen rather in fairy than upon Olympus
now this touches on both
the non-essential sides so you know
fairy tales can be focused upon and
oriented towards a Fallen World a
damaged world full of broken human
beings who don't even realize that
that's the case blind uh you know driven
by their desires like he says you know
the fantasies of Fallen man right it can
also in this sub creation right the
secondary worlds that are generated be
turned towards the supernatural
something that could explain could
redeem could damage even further
depending on what sort of thing we're
talking about
um you know he says this aspect of
Mythology sub creation is too little
considered so that's worth thinking
about in terms of these faces that the
story turns
um and you think about how we grasp this
when we're following out the story We
Are
reading something that is turned in a
magical Dimension towards nature right
we're not performing magic but we're
engaged in something like that and we
also get to see ourselves as human
beings and we can also get to see
something great or something that we're
connected to he also talks about this a
little bit later in the essay in a way
that I think is quite useful as well
he tells us that
[Music]
um
here we go uh fantasy
is made out of the primary world but a
good craftsperson loves his material and
has a knowledge and feeling for clay
stone and wood which only the art of
making can give we get to know this
really pertains towards the natural
right he says by the forging of Graham
this great sword cold iron was revealed
by the making of Pegasus horses were
ennobled by the Trees of the Sun and
Moon root and stock flower and fruit are
manifested in glory and he says and
actually fairies stories deal largely or
the better ones mainly with simple or
fundamental things Untouched by fantasy
but these simplicities are made all the
more luminous by their setting and here
he does he's going to talk about nature
he says for the story maker who allows
himself to be free with nature can be
her lover and not her slave it was in
fairy stories that I first Divine the
potency of the words and The Wonder of
the things such as Stone and wood and
iron tree and grass house and Fire Bread
and Wine
a very interesting
self-disclosure there about the
capacities for this essential Dimension
this essential face of fairy tales to
reveal on tolkien's part he also says
something else that I think is a quite
important
a little bit you know later than making
this distinction he's going to say well
you know I used the word magic
really that might have been a bit of a
mistake here right he says we need a
word for this Elvish craft
but all the words that have been applied
to it have been blurred and confused
with other things magic is ready to hand
and I have used it above but I should
not have done so
so magical face towards nature revealing
to us
what what's actually there not just
engaging in some fantasizing about stuff
but revealing to us the primary World of
Nature that we exist Within
that's a fundamental Dimension so he
says I shouldn't have used magic why
magic should be reserved for the
operations of the magician
art is the human process that produces
by the way
secondary belief art of the same sort if
more skilled and effortless the elves
can also use or so the reports to show
but for the more potent and specifically
Elvish craft I will for lack of a less
debatable word
call enchantment
so that's what's really Central to this
he tells us enchantment produces a
secondary world into which both designer
and spectator can enter to the
satisfaction of their senses while they
are inside but in its Purity it is
Artistic in nature and purpose so
enchantment is oriented by this we could
call it communicative
Dimension but not just any sort of
communication communication of what is
really there in its whatness you could
say right
going on he says magic produces or
pretends to produce an alteration in the
primary World it does not matter by whom
it is said to be practiced Fair mortal
it remains distinct from the other two
it is not an art
but a technique its desire is power in
this world domination of things and
wills
and so he says to the Elvish craft
enchantment fantasy aspires so uh you
know fantasy is one of the key
Dimensions that he's been discussing
here and he says that at the heart of
many man-made stories of the elves lies
open or concealed pure alloyed a desire
for a living realized sub creative art
which however much it may outwardly
resemble it is inwardly wholly different
from the Greed for self-centered power
which is the mark of the mere magician
so instead of talking about the magical
face he could have talked about the face
of Enchantment that is turned towards
nature in these fairy stories or we
could keep on using the term magical
here understanding that it's distinct
from the craft or technique of the
magician all three of these are
important faces that we find in fairy
Stories the stories that have to do with
the land of fairy
and this one is the most Central or most
important one but all three of them do
get entangled with each other and we can
find stories sometimes where not only
the one but the other two are involved
or at least one of the other two is
involved and so I think this is a very
useful distinction for helping us
understand what Tolkien thinks fairy
stories are really all about and what it
is that they do and accomplish for us
their readers those who enter into these
secondary or sub-created worlds